et christophe beaugrand alors il a dit
il était l'invité de l'émission swift
animé par maxime brillault notre ami
qu'est diffusée sur youtube et lui
demander si les animateurs de tf1 avait
vraiment l'interdiction de venir dans
tpm peut regarder s'arrête il dit
souvent que les artistes de téléphone
sont interdits par téléphone d'aller sur
tp oui c'est vrai mais c'est vrai oui
aujourd'hui c'est vrai ça ne l'était pas
c'est vrai parce qu'il ya eu quelqu'un
doit il ya eu beau il ya eu d'aidé des
conflits assez important mais
aujourd'hui effectivement il ya des
contre indications ou dire il vaut mieux
ne pas y aller mais je vois pas
l'intérêt que j'aurai moi aller en
invité dans cette émission à part me
prendre des tomates cerises sur la
figure quel est l'intérêt je suis pas
totalement ma jour les limites
alors c'est vrai qu'on est plutôt cv
avec les stones arriveront à chaque fois
qu'on parle de ses émissions notamment
vigiles
d'ailleurs il a parlé d' ou derrière oui
vous livrer un récit également surpris
qu'il serait mis sur les critiques de
tpm paix et notamment sur vous le gilles
verdez et apparemment ils vous kiffe de
ouf
ah ouais ça rock et pas très agréable
quand assez régulièrement dans une
émission qui est très regardé c'est
souvent où on vous casse du sucre sur le
baudet est ce que vous avez déjà vu
gilles verdez après ses déclarations en
face à face que je n'ai jamais rencontré
super g ne peux pas vous dire peut-être
il a l'air d'un plan b moi je pense que
si jamais je croise direct gilles verdez
dans la rue je pense que je changerais
plutôt de trottoirs si jamais je viens
dans leur émission
ça montrerait éventuellement que j'ai un
intérêt en tout cas que je pense que
leur avis compte mois leur avis ne
compte pas pour ma carrière
alors voilà donc si vous voit dans la
rue déjà ils changent de trottoir
samoëns encourageants sur sa christophe
suis complètement d'accord avec toi moi
je parle réduit la prochaine fois quand
il présentera une émission peut-être
dans six mois nigérian de l'été prochain
c'est denis brogniart oui mais oui il
est aussi mais n'a plus rien donc c'est
difficile mais je voulais juste dire un
mot sur tf1 qu' aujourd'hui en 2018
une chaîne officialise par ses
animateurs une ceinture en mai la
regarde une autre émission a fait
rentrer chaîne et que ça passe en france
comme ça sans qu'ait de réaction c'est
non seulement une honte dans les salles
a raison mais ça montre le
gray de putréfaction de cette chose
complètement d'accord avec vous gilles
sur le fait que vraiment c'est grave
d'avouer qu'ils ne veulent pas que leurs
animateurs initient je vous dire la
vérité pourquoi ils veulent pas parce
qu'ils ont acheté un taux qui choqués en
concurrence voilà sur une autre scène
qu'en ce moment tmp et est devant et qu'
ils veulent pas ils veulent bloquer les
animateurs de leurs chaînes aussi pour
pas faire de promo pour tp mb pourquoi
l'ump passe de jason ils veulent pas on
n'a pas les nikos on a pas de libre n'ya
pas toujours et on s'en fout on l'a dit
ça se passe très bien et voilà et on le
comprend et nous en tout cas sachez que
le groupe canal+ tous les animateurs du
groupe canal+ en tout cas je sais que
les présidents du groupe laisse aller
lord animateur où ils veulent et ils
sont invités
jamel qui fait mine de rien le jamel
comedy kids sur canal+ était l'invité
voilà de tmc tout ça donc il n'ya pas de
souci mais en tout cas eux ils ont un
souci mais il paraît que ça peut changer
voilà dans les prochains jours mais pas
sûr qu'on les reçoive rsa des bastides
et chérie on en a pas besoin
les séries merci en tout cas j je suis
assez d'accord écoulé
[Applaudissements]